each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
okay thank you so this is a very grown
up in serious title but in fact it is
going to be a brief report about me
trying to apply quantitative
verification in the context of molecular
programming so we've already heard about
molecular programming from odisha pyro
and Andrew etc and this is something
that look at is working on and before I
say something about molecular
programming I wanted to say happy
birthday to Luca and also thanks to him
for inspiring me to work on this topic I
started working in systems biology
applying prison about probabilistic
model checking there around two thousand
and fries and this is another
festschrift fog triggers Rosenberg in
2009 in this book appeared and this is a
collection of papers that were written
as you can see here but virtually most
of the key researchers working on
natural computing are just molecular
programming but natural computing to
honor our egos Rosenberg now in fact I
didn't realize until some years later
that Luca was also invited to work and
he his artificial biochemistry paper
appeared there and here is my humble
quantitative verification paper but in
fact it was also our current
experimental collaborator who was
invited to contribute a paper to this
Andrew turbo field so happy birthday and
thanks okay so what we are doing is we
are working at the nanoscale so this is
you know where you measure things in
nanometers and i'm showing you examples
of molecules that i have been working
with so when I was well
working in systems biology I was working
with biologists on this predictive
modeling for this human fgf protein for
signaling and now i'm working with
experimentalist and also with Luke and
our and ruined my groupon with DNA
molecules so what can you do from DNA
molecules and this is an example here
you have a real picture of the artifact
what you can do if you take a very large
long circular strand of DNA and this is
something like two and a half thousand
base pairs this is what it's called a
monomer here and then you also throw in
so-called staples shorter strands of
about 15 to 16 nucleotides and you
select them so that they are
complementary then when you put
everything in a solution they will form
this shape as you can see there is this
join here because the staples will pin
the large strand this large circular
strand in place so this is called
origami and in fact we are trying to
understand the scientific principles
behind forming of the origami structures
but in fact what I wanted to talk about
is molecular programming and molecular
programming is a term that I think was
invented first by masami haghia and it's
big now at Caltech there are there is a
molecular programming project they're
due to Eric Winfrey and I mean the idea
is that what we want to do is we want to
program with molecules and for us
computer scientist this is very
interesting and also very similar to
community completely networks because we
have networks of molecules they can
interact they can also move so we can
talk about motion and you know robotics
in that context now the key observation
is that they are programmable and the
computation proceeds autonomously and of
course this is an ideal playground
and for people like Luca because we need
programming language is another for me
because we need probabilistic
quantitative verification so I'm just
going to now say that what we do is we
focus on programming with DNA molecules
why because it's very versatile can
store information it's already also very
cheap to synthesize you know even if you
I need to synthesize thousands of base
pairs and it is also a very good medium
for designing biosensors so if you want
to detect the presence of absence of a
particular molecule the ideas that you
can design a molecular program to do it
for you and I'll show you some examples
here but of course because of Moore's
law we know that we need to make
computers smaller so there is also an
additional interest of computer
scientists and because they move you can
make molecules move we can talk about
robots at the nanoscale now there are
many applications that have been
envisioned these applications involve
not just designing networks from
molecules but also placing these
networks on these origami structures
that I've showed you this is what I'll
tell you about so I really you know what
to talk about what good quantitative
verification has been what has it what
have we managed to show so far and I'll
finish up with some challenges and of
course because we are talking about
molecules stochasticity is essential and
in particular I work with discrete
stochastic models in particular
continuous time Markov chains and
something sometimes more complex than
that so I'll say something about what
we've done and this is in the setting
focusing on DNA programming where there
is the DSD told it and you told us about
but also there is the prism allergic
it was developed in my group which can
be used either as a back-end to DSD all
can be used directly and I'll just show
you how you know the the progress over
the last three years and I'll finish up
with challenges and directions so DNA
circuits we can use DNA to design
computational circuits now we know that
computational conversion conventional
silicon circuits compute with bits k
zero and one true and false DNA circuits
are very different this was called
computing with soup in an article about
andrew phillips and the idea is that
inputs and outputs are these single DNA
strands and then when you design them
and they're bind and unbind and compute
something so in fact a circuit that can
compute the square root of a 4-bit
number has been demonstrated its takes
10 hours to compute but it was the first
one and this is why we started working
on molecular walkers because it's a
faster technology so how did I get this
is a blog reaction this is not mine this
is how the blogs reacted to this paper
in science so how did I get into this
well in fact Luke I was aware that we
were using prism in systems biology and
he suggested that we look at the design
of his transducer so in this case we are
working on DNA computing with a
restricted class of DNA strands they are
two domains strands so what we have in
this is we have double strands with a
short toehold overhang to which another
you know a matching complementary
toehold can bind but we also have these
single strands which are two domain
because they have a toehold attached and
that toeholds are used to ensure
reversibility of the rear
actions now Lucas contribution to this
was to design a place as an algebra DSD
and then Andrew implemented the tool and
we have worked both with tool with the
tool but also we have worked directly
with prison so what we did is we
following look as encouragement we took
his DNA transducer gate and we managed
to develop a connection from the hd2
prism and demonstrate that there is an
unwanted is a bug in the design when you
try to connect two gates together it is
because of crosstalk now this but can be
fixed and it can be verified now you
might think that this is a great
achievement but in fact Luke already
found this bag manually so our challenge
was to demonstrate that it can be found
automatically okay now i can continue
i'm going to show you that are in this
probabilistic quantitative verification
world we don't just talk about
probabilities such as termination we can
also talk about the probability of
terminations over here we can show that
the probability of error and success is
the same and this was something that was
found with prism but now I have a
finishing master's student and there is
a another design of biosensors which is
quite appealing at a high level the idea
is that we use strengths as inputs but
we use the watson-crick complement to
represent the logical compliment so a
strand is a proposition and now we also
have the compliment and in that paper by
the murrieta they have designed various
gates for implication and you can do our
reasoning because there are various
rules and you can do
a positive so if you have an implication
P implies Q if you throw in not Q you
can reduce not P so it's quite an
appealing system unfortunately there is
a flaw in the design and the floor means
that if you put in p and q
simultaneously then it will deduce are
correctly it will if you put in pee
first thank you it will work but if you
put in Q first and then p it fails okay
now again you might think that this is a
great achievement by my student that in
fact look I found this manually by
reading the paper that I gave him so
again the challenge was to AH show that
this can be done with brisk but in fact
the student has done quite a lot more
work I think analyzing performance which
probably look a counter to in his head
yes so for the final example is the
molecular walkers so I showed you the
picture of the origami tile what you can
do is you can place tracks which is
molecules spaced out at certain distance
and arranged into decision trees and my
experimentalist and return the field he
knows how to make molecules place
molecules at one end make them walk and
also allow them to select branches
according to whether something is
present or absent in there what we have
done because all these are planar we
have analyzed the expressiveness and we
can show that in fact the skin for this
technology they can compute any boolean
function but in addition what we've done
is we have built a this is fritz my PhD
student who is actually doing an
internship here we have built a ctmc
model and then we analyzed the
reliability and performance and also
various aspects of the Walker
and the interesting thing is that this
Walker can actually deadlock it can get
stuck because it can only jump up to two
encourages it can't can't jump up to
three so for example this is an example
but it gets stuck because it has nowhere
to go okay and the final thing I wanted
to say is what we have done very
recently is we can now specify the
parameter synthesis problem in general
in verification people are shifting from
verification to synthesis so shifting
from the question that's the system the
models satisfy a formula to a question
can you give me the model that is
guaranteed satisfied for me now this is
a difficult problem and maybe new
peterman here I can tell you more about
this problem we are looking especially
in a quantitative case we are looking
the Cypriot problem parameter synthesis
so you may have a parametric model can i
find the valuations of the parameters so
that the formula is guaranteed to be
satisfied and we have developed an
algorithm which is based on successive
region refinement and implemented it and
applied it amongst others to the case of
the walk so we can subdivide the region
space and the green area is the area
where they parameter valuations in this
case constant and some rate are
guaranteed to satisfy a given
reliability requirements and this is the
end so I have shown you what we have
been doing it by applying quantitative
verification in molecular programming
and the idea is longer term is to design
to incorporate it in design automation
tools and I have also shown you some
successes some of our predictions
have been confirmed experimentally but
scalability is a huge problem so in
particular for many of these well mixed
solution molecular programs we stopped
at can you guess how many molecules
seven even though in the real solution
in a test tube you have billions so this
is the scalability gap that be
verification researchers have to address
so that's okay thank you